back to back against this guy again yeah
i don't remember i had a b3 he wasn't it
was the the guy with his end game where
he tried for ages yeah i remember i had
a winning end game and a blonde at that
okay let's see if he does the same thing
again oh no he goes Knight f3 mmm I
don't really know how this is played
actually before or what tortoise is
Right I don't know kind of inventing
things here
rupee 8 looks a bit strange all of that
I mean should be five maybe I can do
that preparing um yeah okay Jim you
don't want to take butt cheek on taking
on f3 is also kind of lucky so maybe
this trying to somehow insist that this
night SI is having no square I see you
in the long diagonal but so on edge what
is what is he doing now he sacrificing
this or what no innocent so I can take
right let's do that now we had to put
the night actually maybe it may be still
there so that rook g3 is not in
huh it's very strange position okay
asking you to maybe okay wants to go
kinky one day I became Jack I have night
23 as well Queen here for Queen g2 okay
night g3 it's not bad though okay maybe
you see or maybe you see sacrificing the
exchange that as possible definitely
possible
why probably watch he will probably
sacrifice it okay that's not enough but
still still it's a tricky position and
blitz we look okay well this is jess is
also possible okay take sticks and f6 or
what I can also check c 3 pawn takes
Queen III king cake King takes look sick
okay let's do that maybe that's the
better better choice default check king
cakes Queen age too what's totally
bonkers okay let's get the Queen back
for Queen f6 simple move okay wants to
and 24 ff6
Andrew gave seven
when it's e5 here really do look chief
one white resign yeah that that wasn't
that wasn't great here the Queen gets
sidelined here now i think i'm not sure
if I've trap it actually maybe you
thought I'm trapping it and she has this
we now have d4 and stuff checked should
be I don't know maybe I get get get
enough a tech now so very tense game
where it ends that looked really weird
really wild yeah Jenna Corson the
computer just wants to take that but
yeah it's probably true right i mean the
bishop here it looks nice but it just
looks at f6 I mean objectively speaking
I'm certainly winning rookie have seven
alone is basically defending the whole
king oh my lady I should have taken I
thought that that cannot be bad I can
actually play this check okay I did not
see something here oh that's nice now I
didn't yeah I saw this and I see no a
soul or continuation but this is really
strong though for Queen f6 okay
yeah i was thinking this actually then i
have to go g5 I really overlook that I
cannot play book f7f to play g5 then
it's totally working what is this
actually this is equal material just for
fun yes okay you might as well throw
some dice there okay well thanks for
watching